بطبيعه الحال نحن نتحدث عن جبالي خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه بطريقه لافته
للنظر المعارك تعود وتحديدا من قبل كتائب
القسام المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي تعود
لتضرب بقوه خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه
خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه اكثر من 10 الى 12
اعلانا من كتاب القسام وحدها على ضربات ل
مقاتليها استهدفت اليات وجنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في المناطق الشماليه من قطاع
غزه وتحديدا جباليه التفاح الدرج بدرجه اس
سيه بالاضافه الى المنطقه الشماليه
الغربيه والجنوبيه الغربيه من مدينه غزه
هذا يعيدنا الى مشهد بدايه هذه المعركه
عندما او بدايه توغل البري اواخر اكتوبر
الماضي عندما توغلت الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في هذه المناطق ضغطت بشكل
كبير من الجهه الشرقيه نحو جباليا من
الجهه الشماليه ومن الشماليه الغربيه عند
هذا المربع مربع المخابرات شرق غربي
الصفطاوي ابراج المخابرات وتلك المنطقه
التوام هذه المناطق التي كانت مسرح عمليات
رئيسي لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المتوغلة
خلال توغلها البري الذي استمر قرابه شهرين
منذ اواخر اكتوبر وحتى اواخر ديسمبر عادت
الانتشار وانسحبت ولكنها تضغط الان على
المنطقه الشرقيه مع قصف عنيف تتعرض له هذه
المنطقه بالاضافه الى قصف ايضا على منطقه
تل الزعتر في الاحياء او منطقه الشماليه
الشرقيه من مخيم جباليا كما نعلم هناك
مخيم جباليه للاجئين وهناك جباليه البلد
الضغط كبير على منطقه جباليا البلد من
الجهه الشرقيه بدرجه اساسيه وقصف كبير على
المنطقه للزعتر في الشمال الشرقي لمخيم
جباليه والمنطقه الشماليه ايضا كان هناك
تحرك لافت للنظر في منطقه بيت حنون بيت
حنون التي انسحب الاحتلال منها ويتمركز
على اطرافها بهذا الشكل وفق الدوائر
الحمراء التي نشاهدها هذه المنطقه بيت
حنون تعرضت لقصف عنيف ودمار شبه كامل خلال
الايام والساعات الاولى لهذه المعركه اذا
لا يزال المستوى المنطقه الشماليه او
القاطع الشمالي من قطاع غزه يتعرض لقصف
عنيف وعمليات دقيقه محدده واضحه من قبل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه الامر ينسحب ايضا على
منطقه الوسط مخيم البريج تحديدا كتائب
القسام وسرايا القدس تقول بانها تتصد
لمحاولات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي للتوغل داخل
مخيم البريج عندما نتحدث عن البريج فنتحدث
عن هذه المساحه البسيطه للغايه كيل متر في
ك تقريبا يعني نتحدث عن 1 م مربع فقط يسعى
الاحتلال بكل قوته للضغط على مخيم البريج
ولكنه حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتمكن من التوغل
داخل البريج مع العمليات العسكريه
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه في صد الهجمات من جهه
الشرقيه الامر ينسحب ايضا على المنطقه
الجنوبيه تركيز كبير على خان يونس تهويل
في الاعلام على خان يونس لانها يعتبرها
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مركز السيطره
والعمليات العسكريه لكتاب قسام وسرايا
القدس مركز القياده العمليات العسكريه كما
يقول الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لكنه مع الضغط
الكبير الذي يعرضه لخان يونس من هذه الشكل
بالاسهم التي نراها على الشاشه الجهه
الشرقيه الجهه الشماليه الشرقيه والجهه
الشماليه يضغ غط على خانيونس ولكنه حتى
هذه اللحظه يعجز عن التوغل داخل مدينه
خانيونس هذه المنطقه التي لا تتجاوز بهذا
الشكل حوالي اثنين الى من اربعه الى خ
كيلومترات مربعه فقط قصف عنيف تتعرض له
مدينه خانيونس واحياء الاطراف الشماليه
والشرقيه المقاومه الفلسطينيه تقول بانها
تتصدى بشكل مركز في المنطقه الشرقيه مع
محاولات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التوغل من
المنطقه الشرقيه باتجاه خان يونس هكذا
يبدو المشهد في المناطق الشماليه من قطاع
غزه بعد غياب عن العمليات العسكريه البريه
لفتره الان تعود للتركيز من جديد وايضا
المنطقه الوسطى تتعرض لبعض الضغط من قبل
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والمقاومه ولكن
التركيز ايضا في خانيونس لانها تتعرض ايضا
ضغط كبير يسعى الاحتلال للتوغل في خان
يونس اكثر